sur 180 deux fautes en 62 voire ont été
à tréglamus mais seul endroit que myriam
stocco
en 18 ans agent hospitalier 18 ans
étudiante
18h01 audience 19 ans assistants
dentaires 22 ans mais très interne a
demandé comment une jeune fille peut
devenir miss france
et c'est très simple elle participe aux
élections qui se déroulent dans toute la
france est partie d'abord à des
élections primaires
nous appelons et ensuite au stade
régional des élections régionales qui
sont d'ailleurs organisées par nos
délégations qui sont répartis dans toute
la france
il y à des sélections qui sont faites et
à la fin de l'année nous réunissons une
trentaine fin cette année nous battant
les records puisque nous en avons 36
pour la finale nationale miss france est
une très belle fille première main et je
crois qu'elle qu'elle doit avoir une
certaine moralité
en un mot je crois que c'est une
ambassadrice je me s'agit d'un service
de la beauté je fais si la femme est
assez bonne mais qu'elle est calé bat sa
beauté sera absolument
dans l'ombre elle sera et c'est rentré
miss languedoc
à votre avis à quoi pense un homme
lorsqu'il vous vois je ne sais pas je
peux vous dire à quoi on pense quand une
voix maillot de bain je ne sais pas moi
je défile et qu'est ce qui vous a poussé
à participer à cette élection s'est mal
passée
c'est le titre lui-même puis j'ai vu le
déroulement de l'année du micheline et
j'ai trouvé que c'était très bien tous
les points de vue j'ai vu plusieurs
plusieurs émissions télévisées auquel
avaient participé
je les trouvais vraiment extraordinaire
peut être lui me transporte pour moi on
a tous
professional étant donné que je veux
créer un institut
j'estime que son client
hyper et commercial cela me donnera deux
par beaucoup plus rapide
voilà puis j'estime aussi keaton honneur
de représenter la france dans toutes les
régions dans toutes les manifestations
nationales internationales